Caption: good afternoon welcome to the last
Caption: breakout session before lunch
Caption: and I have to say I've really lucked out
Caption: as a route coordinator this tie rod I've
Caption: got to introduce some incredible
Caption: incredible speakers and in fact this is
Caption: also the second year in the trot that
Caption: I've had the privilege the order of
Caption: introducing daughter to speak this year
Caption: she'll be teaching us how to build
Caption: incredible and great team so without
Caption: further ado please give it up for dollar
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you very much Rob and hi everyone
Caption: so most a lot of you know me I'm Donna
Caption: I've been working in the IT industry for
Caption: 20 years now just had my birthday two
Caption: days ago into a 40 so I'm Ashley old
Caption: thank you
Caption: I'm predominantly my focus has been
Caption: creating great workplace environments
Caption: and building awesome teams I believe
Caption: that all of us deserve to work somewhere
Caption: where we feel valued and empowered and
Caption: for me this belief came from growing up
Caption: in a cult where I didn't have a lot of
Caption: freedom and empowerment and I was also a
Caption: victim of domestic violence at 18 and
Caption: over the years I've had three near-death
Caption: experiences and all of these things have
Caption: really common ated for me in the belief
Caption: that life is too short to go to work
Caption: every day and do something that you
Caption: don't love and that you're not
Caption: passionate about so I try and make every
Caption: day count
Caption: I've worked with a lot of senior
Caption: developers and team leads over the years
Caption: and when I was thinking about putting
Caption: this talk together I was thinking about
Caption: what are the kinds of questions that
Caption: they ask me and what are the things that
Caption: they are challenged with the most and
Caption: the first one was how do you get
Caption: interviewing right you know how do you
Caption: make sure you don't bring the wrong
Caption: people into your team because there's a
Caption: big fear that you have this great team
Caption: and you don't want to ruin it by getting
Caption: the wrong people the other questions
Caption: that I've heard them heard a lot about
Caption: is how do you handle those difficult
Caption: conversations if you've got someone
Caption: who's maybe not performing or there's
Caption: some challenges within the team you know
Caption: how do you handle those conversations as
Caption: easily and painlessly as possible so in
Caption: this talk today I'm going to run you
Caption: through the life cycle
Caption: of building growing and nourishing a
Caption: high-performing team and I'm gonna share
Caption: what I've learned over the many years
Caption: and hopefully some easy strategies in
Caption: the hope that all of us can create
Caption: amazing workplace environments where our
Caption: teams can succeed
Caption: starting with build if you're in here
Caption: today you already have some sort of team
Caption: and whether that's two of you five of
Caption: you or a hundred of you there's already
Caption: gonna be an existing culture in place to
Caption: build a solid foundation the three areas
Caption: that we're going to look at our values
Caption: vision and engagement strategy and I
Caption: guess I just want to clarify when I say
Caption: engagement strategy don't freak out it's
Caption: not going to be all hate sorry it's
Caption: gonna be practical things that as a team
Caption: leader or a senior developer you can do
Caption: with your team so culture is made up of
Caption: the beliefs values and behaviors that
Caption: are shared and demonstrated across the
Caption: organization I've heard lots of
Caption: different lots of different explanations
Caption: over the years but that's the one that I
Caption: like the most
Caption: it's what's actually demonstrated in
Caption: your organization and in your team and
Caption: values can be organization based or they
Caption: can just be team based it depends on how
Caption: clear your values are and how big your
Caption: organization is if your organization has
Caption: high level values you need to really
Caption: make sure that they're broken down so
Caption: that they're meaningful for your team
Caption: and if your organization doesn't have
Caption: clear values then you need to
Caption: collaboratively create the values with
Caption: your team once you've got these values
Caption: you can then recognize and reward
Caption: individuals and teams based on those
Caption: behaviors that are really driving and
Caption: encouraging the culture why do you go to
Caption: work every day why do your team members
Caption: go to work every day do you know what
Caption: they're trying to achieve do they know
Caption: what they're trying to achieve it can be
Caption: really hard to answer that question but
Caption: it's really important that people have a
Caption: clear purpose and understand why they're
Caption: coming to work every day and what
Caption: they're doing so if there's a high-level
Caption: company vision which there often is as a
Caption: as a team lead we need to really break
Caption: that down for our team so that
Caption: meaningful and relevant and then once
Caption: we've got that clear vision you want to
Caption: go even further and really break it down
Caption: into clear goals so everybody knows what
Caption: equals success for me in my role and for
Caption: a team what equals success one of my
Caption: favorite books which I bang on about
Caption: every time I talk is how to find your Y
Caption: by simon Sinek and if you haven't read
Caption: it I definitely recommend it it really
Caption: talks you through a step-by-step process
Caption: of how you figure out what that purpose
Caption: is and it also talks you through a
Caption: process you can do with your team to
Caption: collaboratively figure out what your
Caption: team purpose is which is really cool
Caption: another one is drive by Dan pink he
Caption: talks there's got to be a whole section
Caption: around purpose and why it's so important
Caption: so engagement strategy as well as a team
Caption: lead or even as a senior developer you
Caption: know it's it's our job to make sure that
Caption: there's a plan of how we're going to
Caption: engage our team because if we fail to
Caption: plan we plan to fail so I'm not talking
Caption: anything hardcore I'm just talking a
Caption: one-pager with a few bullet points of
Caption: the key areas that you're going to focus
Caption: on we've already talked about values of
Caption: vision which are two of the key areas
Caption: for the engagement strategy you also
Caption: need to look at collaboration and
Caption: communication so sorry collaboration and
Caption: connection will cover communication
Caption: leader it's human nature to really want
Caption: collaboration and connection with other
Caption: people so as a leader it's our job to
Caption: create those opportunities for our teams
Caption: to connect and to collaborate and to put
Caption: a cadence in place where there's regular
Caption: events and regular sessions so that our
Caption: teams can do that I'm going to run
Caption: through a specific example of how to do
Caption: this in the next slide the other area is
Caption: communication and transparency people
Caption: want regular and transparent
Caption: communication so once again as the
Caption: leader it's our job to create different
Caption: methods that tailor to different styles
Caption: so you need to understand who's in your
Caption: team what their different preferred
Caption: communication styles are and how you're
Caption: going to tailor those comms to really
Caption: suit everybody in your team and then the
Caption: third one is reward and
Caption: how do you show you people that they
Caption: valued in your team obviously saying
Caption: thank you is a nice way to do it and I'm
Caption: pretty easy
Caption: the studies show you that you know you
Caption: need 8 to 1 ratio so eight pieces of
Caption: positive reinforcement and thank you
Caption: before they actually listen and it sinks
Caption: in so I think nothing ever beats verbal
Caption: praise there's plenty of other options
Caption: though Yama has a praise feature which
Caption: is fantastic
Caption: LinkedIn has the new kudos feature which
Caption: I'm on the fence about but it's still an
Caption: option there's a lot of specific
Caption: recognition apps and recognition walls
Caption: that you can implement in your company
Caption: as well and then there's awards so you
Caption: know monthly or quarterly an annual
Caption: award within your team is a great way to
Caption: reward and recognize and then rewards as
Caption: well everybody loves a good voucher or
Caption: you know movie tickets or something like
Caption: that
Caption: and reward and recognition doesn't have
Caption: to be expensive the first implementation
Caption: that I did I had no budget so we created
Caption: a living the values awards program and
Caption: so every month peers would nominate each
Caption: other for displaying the the values of
Caption: the company and we would select a couple
Caption: of winners and we'd print out an a4
Caption: certificate and put it in a frame you
Caption: know it wasn't you know costs maybe five
Caption: dollars but a year later I'd be walking
Caption: around the office and I'd see people
Caption: with these frames on their desk still
Caption: sorry it may sound a little bit you know
Caption: silly but it means a lot to people so
Caption: here's just a really easy example of
Caption: what I'm talking about as a leader you
Caption: don't need to be the one to do all of
Caption: these things but it is our job to set a
Caption: plan and to make sure that these things
Caption: happen so this is an example of some of
Caption: the things that I've done in previous
Caption: organizations that has worked really
Caption: well to make sure that we're bringing
Caption: people together and the slides will be
Caption: available later so you don't have to
Caption: take a photo communication wise once
Caption: again you know what types of
Caption: communication methods are you going to
Caption: do and how often are you're going to do
Caption: them you don't have to be the one to
Caption: implement them but you need to make sure
Caption: that it's happening and communications
Caption: channel this is what I found challenging
Caption: the bigger company the bigger the
Caption: company is we
Caption: you go to find out certain types of coms
Caption: because every company is different right
Caption: and sometimes you just don't even know
Caption: where to start or where to go so having
Caption: a clear cadence like that and to tell
Caption: people where to go especially when
Caption: you're onboarding new people is really
Caption: helpful and recognition programs are in
Caption: that recognition wall like I said a
Caption: visible place where people can recognize
Caption: and show gratitude I actually this is
Caption: one that I've put a team together and
Caption: created because we couldn't find one
Caption: that suited our purpose so you know just
Caption: a place where people can say thanks to
Caption: each other and create that culture of
Caption: gratitude the levels of mental stress
Caption: mental health and stress are just rising
Caption: and rising and rising so there's plenty
Caption: of studies that show you these cultures
Caption: of gratitude really help help people and
Caption: your organization so now you want to
Caption: grow your team you've got you know got a
Caption: nice foundational culture the last thing
Caption: you do is want to hire people that don't
Caption: either have the skills or don't fit into
Caption: the culture of your organization and the
Caption: first thing that I want to address is
Caption: fitting into the culture it's really
Caption: important that we change the language
Caption: about this we should be looking for
Caption: people who are going to enhance our
Caption: culture so culture add as opposed to
Caption: culture fit because culture is always
Caption: changing and more thing it never ever
Caption: stays the same so we don't want people
Caption: that are going to fit we want people
Caption: that are going to add as a team leader a
Caption: senior team member you have different
Caption: levels of influence around this process
Caption: but three of the areas that I think you
Caption: can make a difference in is where to
Caption: find and and how to get great talent
Caption: interviews so often you'll be asked to
Caption: be part of the technical interview
Caption: process or come up with what that looks
Caption: like and also what questions you ask in
Caption: your interview when you're interviewing
Caption: to assess that culture ad and then the
Caption: third area is contributing to your
Caption: employer brand to help attract the right
Caption: talent as well
Caption: does anybody here find it really easy to
Caption: find great technical talent excellent
Caption: I'm not alone couple verify yeah
Caption: whatever
Caption: most of us find it really hard right so
Caption: some of the things that you can do is
Caption: help your recruiters if you've got
Caption: internal recruitment if you don't have
Caption: into recruitment then you'll probably be
Caption: using an agency but you can still help
Caption: them as well but if you've got your
Caption: internal recruiters you know tell them
Caption: where they can find these people just
Caption: give them idea of what kind of companies
Caption: they should be targeting you know what
Caption: kind of meetups that they should go to
Caption: what type of conferences like this that
Caption: they should be at give them some of that
Caption: information that they might not have
Caption: encouraged your company the sponsor
Caption: events like this as well and social
Caption: media you know promote your people
Caption: promote your team promote the type of
Caption: projects that you're doing that is a way
Caption: that you get people to notice your
Caption: organization and to be attracted to come
Caption: and work for your organization LinkedIn
Caption: groups as well or reddit groups there's
Caption: so many different platforms that
Caption: recruiters don't really know about so as
Caption: a technical person you're in the know
Caption: you know where all these people are and
Caption: where they're going so give you a
Caption: recruiter those tips and help them out a
Caption: little the most successful teams that
Caption: I've ever worked in we've had a referral
Caption: percentage of 70% out of all hires so
Caption: ideally you want to be driving your
Caption: internal referral program and really
Caption: encouraging people to refer their
Caption: friends because if it is a great culture
Caption: and a great place to work they're gonna
Caption: want their friends to come and work with
Caption: you so feeding into technical
Caption: requirements for job adverts is the
Caption: other area if you're looking for a
Caption: full-stack developer for example you
Caption: know think about what kind of skills
Caption: that you're going to come up with
Caption: generally you're going to be asked to
Caption: put together a bullet point list of all
Caption: the essential skills that they must have
Caption: and when I think about all the bullet
Caption: points that I've seen on adverts
Caption: normally there's anywhere from seven to
Caption: twelve bullet points of all the things
Caption: that you need to have to apply for that
Caption: job and what I would say is less is more
Caption: every single bullet point you put in
Caption: your advert is basically creating an
Caption: objection and potentially stopping
Caption: someone from applying to that ad good
Caption: people know what they do a full-stack
Caption: developers know what they do right they
Caption: know what skills they need to have so
Caption: use an advert as an opportunity to sell
Caption: your organization not to
Caption: tell people what they should have when
Caption: they already know that and good people
Caption: can work anywhere right there they're
Caption: weighing you up with another six or
Caption: seven different companies so use it to
Caption: really sell all of the benefits that
Caption: your company has and list them all out
Caption: on your advert also use a tool like
Caption: Texas do for a gender-neutral wording
Caption: and it will give you it'll just scan ear
Caption: advert will give you a bit of a report
Caption: on how where it's at if there's anything
Caption: you need to need to change because once
Caption: again you don't want to create
Caption: objections you want as many people as
Caption: possible to apply so here's a bit of an
Caption: example of the way that I would
Caption: recommend structuring an advert the
Caption: first one is about your company but not
Caption: you know we've been around for 15 years
Caption: or not the blah blahs what's the purpose
Caption: who do you add value to who do you help
Caption: what kind of customers do you help and
Caption: how do you change people's lives whether
Caption: it be customers of society if you're a
Caption: company you've got to have a purpose and
Caption: a vision so really sell that because
Caption: that's what people are interested in how
Caption: will we adding value and then exactly
Caption: that how will we adding value in the
Caption: role that I'm gonna join what will I be
Caption: doing how will I contribute to your team
Caption: so once again rather than focusing on
Caption: the blah blahs talk about how you can
Caption: help us this is what we're looking for
Caption: and then like I said if you have to have
Caption: your bullet points but you actually
Caption: don't have to one of the best ads I ever
Caption: wrote was to two paragraphs I had no
Caption: bullet points my boss absolutely hated
Caption: it at the time he was like this is the
Caption: worst advert I've ever seen in my life
Caption: and I hired one of the best candidates
Caption: I've ever hired from Island who saw that
Caption: ad and applied to that ad so you don't
Caption: need to have bullet points but if you
Caption: have to try and keep it to a maximum of
Caption: three and then once again use it as a
Caption: cell use it as an actual advert to sell
Caption: all of the benefits that you have
Caption: because you know a lot of the time you
Caption: are gonna have a lot of benefits and not
Caption: everybody has them I had a client
Caption: recently who was providing his team with
Caption: volunteer days paid volunteer days and
Caption: it wasn't on his advert and it wasn't on
Caption: any of you know the careers paid or any
Caption: thing else and I was like why don't you
Caption: have this on there and he's like well
Caption: everybody does that don't they know so
Caption: you won't you won't even realize some of
Caption: the things that other companies don't do
Caption: and then people provide an opportunity
Caption: for someone to call someone crazy or
Caption: email someone rather than just having
Caption: you know a I scan through and spit out
Caption: who's suitable and who's not suitable
Caption: people especially you will know in the
Caption: Perth market right everyone's always a
Caption: bit concern that their employer might
Caption: find out that they're applying for
Caption: another job so sometimes they're gonna
Caption: want to have a confidential chat with
Caption: someone so give them that option on your
Caption: advert I know it's a little crazy but it
Caption: really works and then interviewing so
Caption: hopefully you've got some decent
Caption: candidates in your pipeline by this
Caption: point through all the different things
Caption: that we've done over the years I was
Caption: doing a bit of a calculation I think
Caption: I've done over 3,000 interviews and this
Caption: is some of the feedback this is based on
Caption: some of the feedback that I've collected
Caption: from candidates and from hiring managers
Caption: the first one is to make your interview
Caption: process streamlined so try and keep it
Caption: between two and four interviews or two
Caption: and four processes and be really
Caption: transparent with the candidates at the
Caption: beginning of this is what it's going to
Caption: be this is how many interviews you're
Caption: going to have these are the type of
Caption: people that you're going to be meeting
Caption: try and be as straightforward and as
Caption: open as possible with them and sometimes
Caption: if you think it might change just tell
Caption: them that just be transparent and
Caption: upfront at the beginning consistent you
Caption: want to be comparing apples with apples
Caption: you know if you're recruiting for don't
Caption: net developers then you want to make
Caption: sure that the questions or that the
Caption: tests that you have that the process is
Caption: the same because that's from a fairness
Caption: perspective that is the best way to do
Caption: it relevant if it's a development role
Caption: then you want to be testing their coding
Caption: skills right if it's the pre-sales role
Caption: then you want to be testing their
Caption: precise ability or facilitation ability
Caption: if it's for UX so make sure that it's
Caption: really relevant to the role that you're
Caption: recruiting for don't just have a blanket
Caption: standard process make sure that
Caption: subjective so the only way you can be
Caption: objective is to provide your
Caption: interviewers with training so
Caption: rather than with training on how to
Caption: assess people what equals pass what
Caption: equals fail what do you do if you're on
Caption: the fence train them on how to use
Caption: behavioral questions behavioral
Caption: questions are really important and we'll
Caption: give some examples of them shortly give
Caption: them training on unconscious bias
Caption: because we all have it it's not it's not
Caption: whether we do or don't it's just about
Caption: how we're our way of what it is and the
Caption: last one is around diversity of
Caption: interviewers make sure that when you're
Caption: putting your interviewers together
Caption: you've got a level of diversity there I
Caption: did a management round interview a few
Caption: months ago and the recruiter and I
Caption: realized that we'd put a technical
Caption: interview together and we'd it was a guy
Caption: who was you know in his late 30s early
Caption: 40s I'm really bad with age so I don't
Caption: know how old he was but he was you know
Caption: old like me
Caption: and he was from the UK white white male
Caption: from the UK at that age group and we'd
Caption: given to we'd put too technical
Caption: interviewers that were both white males
Caption: from the UK of the same age group
Caption: together to make that assessment so
Caption: that's not helping anybody right so make
Caption: sure that there's diversity in who's
Caption: part of your interviews demonstrably so
Caption: whatever skills the person needs to have
Caption: you want to see them in your interview
Caption: you need to see them doing it if it's
Caption: coding they need to code if it's you
Caption: know if it's pre-sales and they give
Caption: them a scenario and get them to talk
Caption: through and pretend that you're the
Caption: customer get them to talk through that
Caption: scenario if it's if it's UX get them to
Caption: run a workshop for you or facilitate
Caption: something so you really want to make
Caption: sure that you get to see their skills
Caption: the last one is making sure that it's
Caption: safe you know I'm sure everyone's
Caption: probably had a bad experience with
Caption: interviewing so it's not about softening
Caption: our interview process but it's about
Caption: being kind think about the worst
Caption: interviews that you've had in the best
Caption: interviews that you've had and then
Caption: let's do it a different way a better way
Caption: when someone's coming and working for
Caption: you they're not going to be freaking out
Caption: and nervous and stressed most of the
Caption: time so you want to give them the chance
Caption: to perform at their best which means
Caption: making them comfortable think about the
Caption: environment give them some War
Caption: to make sure that you're not sitting
Caption: three people across a giant boardroom
Caption: table and really intimidating them so
Caption: that safety factor is really helpful so
Caption: you've checked their skills and now it's
Caption: about making sure that the values and
Caption: the beliefs and the attitude is in line
Caption: and it's gonna add to your culture we
Caption: all know that a bad apple spoils the
Caption: whole bunch so prevention is much better
Caption: than cure so you really want to dig deep
Caption: in your interviews to make sure you're
Caption: getting the right people so behavioral
Caption: based questions can be created based on
Caption: your values so this is one of the
Caption: reasons they're having those underlying
Caption: values is so important if your values
Caption: are about learning then ask them to tell
Caption: you about a time where they've learned
Caption: something new if your values are about
Caption: teamwork or you know working well in a
Caption: team then ask them about a time where
Caption: they've helped their teammates with
Caption: something one of my favorite questions
Caption: is to ask if it wasn't for money what
Caption: would you spend your time doing because
Caption: it gives you a really good insight into
Caption: what someone's passionate about another
Caption: one that I really like is to tell me
Caption: about a time where you've improved
Caption: something or where you've brought some
Caption: innovation into your team but like I say
Caption: you really need to tailor these to your
Caption: specific organizational values one of
Caption: the things that I would say as a bit of
Caption: a red flag is if somebody can't tell you
Caption: about a time where they've failed or
Caption: made a mistake so I always ask to tell
Caption: me about a time where you failed and it
Caption: does depend on your culture but I did
Caption: say no to someone recently who said to
Caption: me I don't do anything unless I'm a
Caption: hundred percent sure that I'm gonna
Caption: succeed at it and for the culture of the
Caption: organization that I was working in at
Caption: the time it just wasn't that wasn't a
Caption: good fit because our culture was all
Caption: about trying failing making it safe to
Caption: fail innovating so that was just not the
Caption: right fear and I gave that transparent
Caption: feedback to that candidate after the
Caption: interviews had finished and he was told
Caption: he was unsuccessful I rang him and had a
Caption: conversation with him and I asked him to
Caption: come back in six months time and I asked
Caption: him to go and try and make some mistakes
Caption: so I think there's a level of honesty
Caption: and transparency that people really
Caption: appreciate and there's no downside to
Caption: that
Caption: employee brand is really important
Caption: especially when you're trying to attract
Caption: talent from eastern states or from
Caption: overseas you know a lot of the time they
Caption: don't know who we are or what the brand
Caption: is I'm a little bit lucky now in that
Caption: aspect but in general people have never
Caption: known who the company was that I work
Caption: for so encourage your team to meetups
Caption: meetups and community events are amazing
Caption: right so attend them host them talk them
Caption: talk at them encourage your company to
Caption: sponsor as a lead speaker people
Caption: Spreaker people's personal achievements
Caption: professional achievements everything is
Caption: beneficial to your organization if your
Caption: team is being successful so it's all of
Caption: your success the best place to work
Caption: awards are an amazing way as well to
Caption: attract overseas talent so if you can
Caption: get your organization to go for one of
Caption: those they've been really helpful in my
Caption: experience careers page make sure that
Caption: you've got a great careers page on your
Caption: website or on LinkedIn that you can put
Caption: real pictures and stories and videos
Caption: that show your team and show you the
Caption: types of projects that you do it's a
Caption: really great way to attract people once
Caption: again and benefits benefits benefits
Caption: benefits list all of the benefits on
Caption: your careers page as well so you've got
Caption: a great culture you're hiring great
Caption: people and now you want to keep
Caption: enhancing and not having any issues so
Caption: to build a great team we need to nourish
Caption: it and the three areas that are really
Caption: important I empowerment development and
Caption: leadership so in my experience
Caption: empowering a team is absolutely the
Caption: fastest way to scale and succeed in my
Caption: last role I was in Melbourne for nine
Caption: months and I had 80 direct reports 80
Caption: developers consultants direct reports
Caption: which is kind of insane right like 80
Caption: like what do you meant to do with 80 so
Caption: one of the things that I did
Caption: collaboratively with the team is put
Caption: together a leadership group and with
Caption: that leadership group we
Caption: with a collaborative strategy of what we
Caption: wanted to achieve over the next 12
Caption: months and then each of those people
Caption: within that team we're empowered to own
Caption: and drive different initiatives across
Caption: the state and bring in other people from
Caption: the teams and over like nine months we
Caption: we hit our 15% growth target and we had
Caption: 95 percent retention so empowering
Caption: people makes your life a lot easier as a
Caption: leader and it's what people want so it's
Caption: the easiest way to really build a great
Caption: team
Caption: before I was in Melbourne I was back
Caption: here in w.a and we grew our team from 25
Caption: to 50 in six months and we retained a
Caption: 98% average employee satisfaction score
Caption: so once again empowerment empowerment
Caption: empowerment it works collaboratively set
Caption: goals with your team and with
Caption: individuals so I'm a big fan of letting
Caption: people if they understand what the
Caption: vision is and what the purpose is let
Caption: people come up with their own kpi's you
Caption: know let people come up with their own
Caption: goals because then they're going to pick
Caption: something that they believe in and that
Caption: they want to achieve and it's a lot
Caption: easier to then let them figure out how
Caption: they get there it's our job as a leader
Caption: to provide if there's any boundaries if
Caption: there's any specific you know reporting
Caption: and requirements or deadlines that they
Caption: need to hit and it's our job to make
Caption: sure that we provide them the support
Caption: that they need and make it safe to fail
Caption: but other than that let them have that
Caption: empowerment the other thing that we need
Caption: to do is make sure that within our team
Caption: we've got the right mix of skills and
Caption: roles to achieve the goals and that can
Caption: be tricky so one of the things that
Caption: really works is making sure that you're
Caption: balancing the strengths areas within
Caption: your team if you let people do what
Caption: they're good at
Caption: generally speaking they love what
Caption: they're good at right so if you can put
Caption: a team together and every single person
Caption: is getting to do what they're good at
Caption: and what they love it's happy days so
Caption: think about what hats are needed as well
Caption: within the team you know do you need a
Caption: scrum master do you need a stakeholder
Caption: someone who's gonna do stake order
Caption: management you need a technical go-to
Caption: person you know mentor do you need a
Caption: cheerleader in your team do you need
Caption: someone commercial
Caption: awareness or delivery management do you
Caption: need someone who's risk management
Caption: focused so think about all those
Caption: different hearts they're not necessarily
Caption: role titles but their hats that need to
Caption: be worn within different teams and then
Caption: make sure that you consider those hats
Caption: when you're putting together a team and
Caption: and putting together those strengths and
Caption: also recruiting new people into the team
Caption: think about those hats as well once
Caption: again Dan pink has a section around
Caption: autonomy in his book which is talks
Caption: about all of this in a lot more detail
Caption: and Mark Matson has an awesome book
Caption: which a lot of you have probably read
Caption: the subtle art of not giving a Fu CK and
Caption: that book is awesome because it talks
Caption: about how our brains love solving
Caption: problems that's what they want to do
Caption: they just want to solve problems so if
Caption: you fix all of the problems it's just
Caption: going to create more problems so you
Caption: actually need to find the problems that
Caption: you love and find the problems that your
Caption: team loves and then like just give them
Caption: all of those problems and now have fun
Caption: solving them sounds so simple right
Caption: people always want to keep either
Caption: developing themselves or developing
Caption: their career so building a great team
Caption: it's really important that we enable
Caption: this as a leader so creating an
Caption: objective career pathway is important
Caption: one of the frameworks that I really like
Caption: is this the fear framework SFI a and
Caption: that's a specific IT framework that has
Caption: different levels and different
Caption: capability descriptions that people can
Caption: use to progress through the organization
Caption: I don't believe as a leader we should be
Caption: pushing people or babying people when it
Caption: comes to career development it but it is
Caption: important that we set up a framework and
Caption: that we support them with what they're
Caption: trying to do the first capability
Caption: framework that I ever set up was super
Caption: basic just with a spreadsheet you know I
Caption: worked with a couple of the technical
Caption: people and we developed the different
Caption: role titles and the different
Caption: descriptions and rolled it out within
Caption: the business and it was great because it
Caption: was transparent people just want to know
Caption: the what why the hell red if I have a
Caption: great one called mad skills which is
Caption: open source so anybody can access it and
Caption: once again roll titles and a really
Caption: clear description
Caption: transparent processes is important so
Caption: when it comes to salaries salary reviews
Caption: when it comes to promotions and how you
Caption: get promotions and when you get
Caption: promotions it's really really important
Caption: that you have a clear clearly defined
Caption: process and that people know how it
Caption: works and they know what they need to do
Caption: to achieve those things and tick those
Caption: boxes and get their promotion and from a
Caption: salary perspective it's really important
Caption: that they understand how you're
Caption: reviewing and how its measured you know
Caption: what data do you review what market
Caption: rates do you look at people just want to
Caption: understand a lot of time you know even
Caption: if you're not able to give them much
Caption: because of market rates and CPI and
Caption: different things as long as you can
Caption: explain how you've thought about it what
Caption: the process was and why this is the
Caption: reason they're gonna be a lot more
Caption: forgiving and a lot more patient with
Caption: you learning and growing and learning
Caption: growing developing in my experience is
Caption: great people really want to know and be
Caption: able to do this within their
Caption: organization so enabling people to keep
Caption: progressing with whatever type of
Caption: learning and developing and training
Caption: that they want is really important
Caption: whether it be formal PD plans whether it
Caption: be quarterly catch ups with people where
Caption: you set a couple of goals for the
Caption: quarter ratify we did retros which was
Caption: really great so the whole purpose of the
Caption: Retro was for people to gather feedback
Caption: and to set goals and look at how I'm
Caption: developing and how I'm improving so
Caption: making sure once again that you're as a
Caption: leader enabling people to keep learning
Caption: is super important as a leader it's
Caption: really important that we have good self
Caption: reflection so we need to understand what
Caption: our own strengths and weaknesses are and
Caption: we need to have a growth mindset and be
Caption: looking to improve and be open to taking
Caption: on feedback it's super important we all
Caption: know the research around people don't
Caption: leave company as they leave managers and
Caption: we've the feedback that I've received
Caption: over all of those thousands of
Caption: interviews absolutely I would say 70% of
Caption: the feedback is that that's the reason
Caption: that people are leaving so the biggest
Caption: complaint that I receive is that man
Caption: don't listen just repeat that managers
Caption: don't listen and in my experience when
Caption: people come to us with a problem there's
Caption: two main ways that we respond the first
Caption: is we try and solve it for them oh just
Caption: do this I'll just do that what did you
Caption: do that for it's so easy for us to want
Caption: to just solve their problem the second
Caption: is that we give reasons for the issue
Caption: which can come across as defensive oh
Caption: well yeah that's because of this oh you
Caption: don't know what's going on behind the
Caption: scenes this is going on so that is not a
Caption: good option either people just want to
Caption: be heard and acknowledged most of the
Caption: time so the next time that somebody
Caption: comes to you with a problem or a
Caption: complaint
Caption: honestly just try listening and
Caption: acknowledging them like this and then
Caption: use questions so ask them for ideas on
Caption: how they think that they could fix the
Caption: issue or fix the problem
Caption: ask them for what support they need or
Caption: they're looking for a lot of the time
Caption: people will come up with the answer and
Caption: will fix it themselves they just want
Caption: you to listen but there is no shortage
Caption: of challenging conversations and
Caption: difficult conversations but you do need
Caption: to have as a leader I prefer the term
Caption: courageous conversations channeling a
Caption: bit of bren Brown because it takes
Caption: courage to be honest and transparent
Caption: with people and to practice empathy and
Caption: in Brenham Brown's book daring greatly
Caption: she talks about the difference between
Caption: empathy and sympathy and it's a really
Caption: interesting description of it so I would
Caption: add that on your reading list as well if
Caption: you haven't read that one yet but people
Caption: respect trust and value if you
Caption: consistently do this and I say practice
Caption: empathy because it can definitely be
Caption: learnt as a as a born perfectionist with
Caption: unrealistic expectations I have learned
Caption: this the hard way you absolutely can
Caption: practice it and you do need it to be a
Caption: good leader the other thing that we are
Caption: often afraid of of giving feedback is
Caption: that it will destroy our relationship
Caption: with the person but when you actually
Caption: see
Caption: about when was the time that somebody
Caption: gave me some constructive feedback and
Caption: gave me some things that I could improve
Caption: on if you think about a scenario that's
Caption: happened for you personally and when
Caption: it's been delivered in a in a nice way
Caption: generally speaking what you find is that
Caption: it strengthens your relationship and it
Caption: strengthens your bond with that person
Caption: because you know that they're going to
Caption: be honest with you and you know that you
Caption: can trust them when I left ratify a few
Caption: months ago I had 12 people reach out to
Caption: me and sent me an email and asked me if
Caption: I could give them some constructive
Caption: feedback of how they can keep
Caption: progressing like that's amazing that
Caption: shows such a huge level of trust that
Caption: they have reached out and asked for that
Caption: type of feedback so there's lots of
Caption: different feedback models that you can
Caption: use I've put this one together because I
Caption: think it's a nice balance model and yeah
Caption: I like it so that's first and I've
Caption: caught it ours because it is all about
Caption: us it's all about us working together so
Caption: the first one is tell the person your
Caption: truth what's the behavior that you've
Caption: observed what is it that you're
Caption: concerned about the second one is seek
Caption: to understand their truth because
Caption: there's your truth and there's their
Caption: truth and it's very rarely the same and
Caption: often the real truth is somewhere in the
Caption: middle so seeking to understand their
Caption: truth can take quite a while this part
Caption: of the conversation can be a good half
Caption: an hour of really practicing those
Caption: listening skills and just understanding
Caption: what is what is their truth once you've
Caption: really understood that you can recommend
Caption: some behavior change that you're looking
Caption: for now if it's if it's quite serious
Caption: and it's essential then you need to set
Caption: clear expectations and potentially
Caption: consequences of if the behavior doesn't
Caption: change what's going to happen but a lot
Caption: of the time I've found that just by
Caption: recommending and a suggestion of how you
Caption: think that they should change things
Caption: generally speaking people want to keep
Caption: improving and they have the willingness
Caption: to change and the third is is ask them
Caption: what support they need so that's making
Caption: sure that they've got everything they
Caption: need to be able to make the change
Caption: and also it helps confirm that they've
Caption: understood what it is that you've asked
Caption: them to do as well or the feedback that
Caption: you've given going back to Bernie Brown
Caption: again and Darren greatly she says clear
Caption: is kind unclear is unkind and that's one
Caption: of my favorite quotes because in my
Caption: experience it's really true if you're
Caption: clear and you're honest with someone
Caption: that isn't that is the kind thing to do
Caption: because they might not be aware of
Caption: what's going on and if no one's gonna
Caption: tell them the truth they're gonna go
Caption: their whole career they're gonna go to
Caption: their next job and their next job and
Caption: they're not going to understand what
Caption: everybody is saying about them or the
Caption: reason that they weren't successful
Caption: so clearer is kind here is a bit of a
Caption: snapshot of the building blocks that we
Caption: have covered today to enable building a
Caption: great team in my experience I did so
Caption: well with time I timed it last night I
Caption: took ten minutes longer so that means we
Caption: have time for some Q&A so it does take
Caption: courage to be a leader and to step into
Caption: all of this as opposed to away from all
Caption: of this because it's really easy to just
Caption: put your blinkers on and pretend that
Caption: nothing's going on but I do promise that
Caption: it gets easier the more you practice
Caption: these techniques and it's a real
Caption: privilege to be a leader to be able to
Caption: help people live their best lives and
Caption: come to work and you know have a have an
Caption: amazing time and love what they do
Caption: it's an absolutely huge privilege so I
Caption: do have a bunch of stickers down here
Caption: I'm also would love to connect with
Caption: people on Twitter or LinkedIn and I am
Caption: available after this for any questions
Caption: as well but we may as well and I'm
Caption: springing this money Rob sorry but I'm
Caption: more than happy to do some curly
Caption: questions if anyone's got any yes
Caption: hello
Caption: just jumping back to your job ads yes so
Caption: you talked about potentially eliminating
Caption: the bullet points and you said you've
Caption: done that before successfully I guess
Caption: the first thing that springs to mind for
Caption: me then is that would create like a lot
Caption: of noise that you need to process of
Caption: qualified people for the position you're
Caption: looking for and then also potentially it
Caption: would be a barrier in itself in that if
Caption: I'm a.net developer and I don't know
Caption: that this is a dotnet job specifically I
Caption: might be less inclined to apply for that
Caption: do you find that happens at all yes so
Caption: I'm not saying take away the the job
Caption: description if that makes sense that was
Caption: a.net developer role then firstly a
Caption: title is probably going to be don't net
Caption: developer but when you're talking about
Caption: the what yeah might not be it might be
Caption: senior consultant or developer you are
Caption: correct but when you're talking about
Caption: your description of what you're going to
Caption: bring to the team what you're going to
Caption: do the description would say that so it
Caption: would say you'll be working with a
Caption: fantastic team of developers bringing
Caption: your dotnet skills to be able to enhance
Caption: this particular application or adding
Caption: value to this customer through your
Caption: exceptional net skills so you can still
Caption: put it's just about when you've got this
Caption: criteria this criteria this criteria
Caption: it's it's tiring for people and it's
Caption: off-putting for people the other part of
Caption: your question though was mold lots and
Caption: lots of applicants so I don't know about
Caption: your everyone's experience here but for
Caption: me I get the same amount of crappy
Caption: irrelevant applications that come
Caption: through regardless of how many bullet
Caption: points I put on my job advert sorry
Caption: you're always going to have a bunch that
Caption: are completely not relevant but what
Caption: you're trying to capture is that small
Caption: portion that actually are exceptional
Caption: that you don't want to miss out on so I
Caption: would always take more over less because
Caption: you're still going to get all the crappy
Caption: ones unfortunately where I would say
Caption: this may not this wouldn't work is if it
Caption: is a non if it's a job advert for it
Caption: admin assistant for example if it's a
Caption: job advert where you know you're going
Caption: to get heaps of good applications you
Caption: don't need to worry about this but this
Caption: is technical people you really want to
Caption: get the best applications cool we have
Caption: time for a couple more questions I can't
Caption: see anything a question for which might
Caption: also flip over the other side to people
Caption: actually applying how much weight in the
Caption: modern world do you put on receiving CVS
Caption: and what methods do you use to pick the
Caption: wheat from the chaff
Caption: finally finding the diamonds in the
Caption: rough yes I'm a big fan of being able to
Caption: apply without Seavey's I'm a big fan of
Caption: being able to use LinkedIn profiles with
Caption: the K via that you do need to flesh out
Caption: your LinkedIn profile with a description
Caption: for roles not just role titles which I
Caption: have seen a few were those that's not
Caption: particularly helpful and I was able to
Caption: apply for my last roll with my LinkedIn
Caption: CV and that is becoming more and more
Caption: popular so I would say if you've got a
Caption: LinkedIn profile start thinking about
Caption: using that and flesh it out just a
Caption: little bit but CV is a I guess there are
Caption: there a baseline right you're looking at
Caption: for me I'm looking at what type of roles
Caption: the person's done what type of
Caption: experience do they have how long they've
Caption: stayed at different companies one thing
Caption: I'd always be careful of is calling our
Caption: contract rules versus permanent rules so
Caption: sometimes I look at a CV and someone's
Caption: kind of gone three months six months six
Caption: months and I've gone all you know they
Caption: move around a bit but they were contract
Caption: roles but they didn't put it on their CV
Caption: so that's kind of a bit of a tip that I
Caption: would say but I think either CVS or
Caption: LinkedIn profiles are still you need
Caption: something to get an idea to help weed
Caption: through all the applications but
Caption: referrals is always the best referrals
Caption: referrals referrals cool so one last
Caption: question
Caption: hi do you have any tips for introverts
Caption: to be more effective where they have the
Caption: option to influence team culture in
Caption: sorry who team culture what was the
Caption: first bit so my personality is more like
Caption: 80% of an introvert so and I'm in a
Caption: position where I can influence team
Caption: culture and I'm like part of a new team
Caption: that's forming and storming right now so
Caption: that's where I struggle I'm just
Caption: wondering if you have any tips for yeah
Caption: I think great question because I'm sure
Caption: at least 50% of the room yeah I have the
Caption: same problem so I think it's it's no
Caption: different in some ways it's no different
Caption: whether you're an extrovert or an
Caption: introvert because in as a as a team
Caption: leader or as a senior person what it's
Caption: all about it is getting of getting other
Caption: people together with you to do it
Caption: together
Caption: it's not about needing to do it on
Caption: yourself by yourself so you know figure
Caption: out who are those who's passionate about
Caption: culture who's on the same page about
Caption: what what you're trying to do within
Caption: your team and who's passionate about
Caption: success and then have those
Caption: conversations you know together and then
Caption: get a few people with you to help grow
Caption: that within the team so you don't have
Caption: to be standing up growing rah rah rah
Caption: everybody do this I find a lot of the
Caption: leaders that I've met the best leaders
Caption: I've ever met have been introverts so
Caption: yeah it's it's more about is it the
Caption: right type of company you're working for
Caption: where they value you because that is one
Caption: of the challenges that I've seen
Caption: especially in consulting where the only
Caption: people that get promoted or valued are
Caption: people that are loud salesy and so that
Caption: can be a challenge is the culture of the
Caption: company that you're working for do they
Caption: value you as an inch of her or not and
Caption: sometimes that can be a problem thank
Caption: you that was thought-provoking and
Caption: inspiring could you please join me for
Caption: one last round of applause for Donna
Caption: thank you
Caption: thank you and there's lots of stickers
Caption: [Applause]